vrai j'aimerais que les
gouvernements soit à l'image de la
population j'aimerais que les
institutions soit à l'image de la
population
j'aimerais que
l'administration soit à l'image de la
population j'aimerais que la
politique soit à l'image de la
population peuple noir Rebe Gan indien
toi qui fais cette minorité majorité de
qure coins du monde it toi c'est ton toi
il est à toi c'est pas trop tard yeah
pas trop tard
comm un mot d'amour pour l'Afrique la
Palestine un mot d'amour pour les
musiques le flamenco le guagano un mot
d'amour toujours partout pour tout ce
qui bouge
touche j'aimerais que la
télévision so à l'image de la
population j'aimerais que le droit que
le
savoir soit à l'image de la
population j'aimerais que la
mondialisation soit au service de la
population j'aimerais que l' que la
justice soit au service de la la
population
j'aimerais que les
gouvernement soit à l'image de la
population